hey everybody giving me trouble for no
good reason
there we go huh how's everyone doing
tonight how am i doing uh-huh
I I'm I'm not gonna say I'm starting to
lose my mind but it's uh it's wandering
off on its own even more than as usual
let's go with that
oh that's not bad I haven't had this one
before so that's that's nice uh yeah I
have no plan for this one cuz planning
is work and uh I just I can't I can't
plan right now ah thanks easy bond I I
appreciate that reference they're coming
to take me away oh you too well they
were coming to take me away but it
violate you social distancing rules so
they're just leaving me here they looked
a straightjacket though uh no plan
sounds good oh good that's what relieved
watching Dolittle was a mistake yeah I
could have told you that I saw Dolittle
well my kid I didn't make a video on
that one but then what's annoying about
that is I'm like say cats Dolittle isn't
even bad in a way that's interesting
it's just bad it's just not well made it
doesn't suffer from the bizarre what
were they thinking kind of decisions
that went into something like cats which
makes cats worth watching in a way that
Dolittle isn't even though I can't say
that
it's a better movie perhaps where you
watch Muppet Treasure Island great
advice on cabin fever I am I'm really
partial to Muppet Treasure Island
because I love the Muppets and I
actually legitimately love the story of
Treasure Island like strand and I love
variants on it like I love the
miniseries version with Eddie Izzard I
love Treasure Planet
I'd love I just love Treasure Island
just flat-out the fly scene was the only
thing that I'm yeah positive reaction
I'm surprising anything did you're the
same as content creator on YouTube
hahaha boy if that's not an indictment
of this platform I don't know what is
have your family asked why you now leave
rooms yelling Macavity I've know cuz I'm
trapped alone that was the sad answer
it's day I don't know in the Big Brother
house Muppet Treasure Island is
fantastic and I also as Tim Curry so big
points well yes that's always a bonus
right there how do you love the fact
that I'm in like a nice kind of dressy
top and pajama pants how's that for
quarantine chic I agree with your love
Simon review I can't stand Martin yeah
and I know you're not supposed to like
him but like I just liked him I think
more than I was supposed to they
finished it an adaptation of Treasure
Island starring Tom Baker oh dang okay I
may need to look into that
i sorry watch clue the other night
another great Tim Curry movie I watched
that with Liz
shortly before lockdown started after
stumbling upon some old chapter books
from the early 90s I've been inspired to
write oh hang on
it's prior to write short stories again
that's great to hear Connor the
alternative would get us to monitor well
you're implying that the only
alternative would be for me to not have
pants on at all which yes yes that
that will give me demonetised flames on
the side of my face
I hate Martin so much I shut off the
movie at one point legit I powered
through Richard is the best tag Cooper
is not my favorite fictional pet I have
a decal of tad Cooper on my car and it
says I super believe then they'll
believe in my dragon pal and me
pantsless would be fun though it would
be but I think I need to create a new
patreon tier before I start doing
pantsless livestreams check out the UK
National Theatre live Treasure Island
with Arthur Darvill ooh hmm only got one
more day though
tell us about your necklace that looks
cool Oh then have you seen The
Inbetweeners no I haven't um do you like
Neapolitan pizza I don't know what that
is I know a Neapolitan ice cream is when
a crimes disc heard the hare Macavity is
not bad
so the necklace this wood and actually
the earrings as well these were given to
me by two different co-workers who
basically know about this side of myself
and have decided to if they're getting
rid of jewelry the first thing they do
is bring it in to work and say hey do
you would you wear this so that's where
this came from and I actually she gave
it to me a bit before maybe actually a
month before the lockdown but I had to
order a cord to put it on because it was
just it was just this without anything
to actually wear on my neck well you can
at least a pantsless in your regular
vids well I do so far as you know what's
your favorite ice cream it's mood
dependent I tend to favor things that
are either somewhere in the vicinity of
mint or caramel um but I don't have like
a specific always get
flavo it's pretty mood dependent
thoughts on the farewell Sarah Jane
audio I need to try and listen to it
again I I couldn't finish it because the
problem was I had the video up and if
there's a video component it's hard for
me to not watch but you really shouldn't
or at least I shouldn't with something
like that because I wanted there to be I
wanted it to be something like PS where
you know they had you know storyboards
or something but you know they they
didn't it was just the guy who's reading
it and he's eating to be doing fine but
I couldn't get into it and once I saw
him in that boot so I what I need to do
is I need to pull it up and like beat
off somewhere else and not looking at
the video I need to try again what's
your favorite tar wars episode well you
know the the La Brea Tar Pits Star Wars
Episode was particularly particularly
good I'm sorry I don't mean to make fun
of people for typos I just it was too
easy
I ordered a new coat that I knew would
be too small in the hopes of having a
goal to lose a few pounds in quarantine
but arrived in it fits fine I'm glad it
fit fine and also thank you poker Pope
the thing is like I generally don't
encourage people to do that cuz I know
that never works for me and I don't know
too many people it does work for that
whole oh I'll get this and then oh I'll
fit it later I need to replace my garter
belt because it's from probably twelve
years ago about three inches smaller on
the waist yeah it cuts in my go-to
movies when I need comfort a heart
Laozi disaster movies everything from
2012 to fire twist fire twist oh god I
can't even act surprised
best Buffy episode Oh
that is that is tough I mean part of me
is tempted to say Restless but that
one's so bizarre that and it's so a
typical I know he did a top ten Buffy
episodes list years ago I can't remember
what I actually put at the table I think
it might have been becoming part two I
can't remember though this there's a lot
of good ones have you checked the Doctor
Who videos made by full-fat videos no I
saw that they went up happened in the
mood for Doctor Who dissections lately
um likes to bagful put one out lately on
the I'm Big Finish and I'd watch that
but I don't know I just know and it's
kind of funny with deep dive dissections
a little bit like fan theory I tend to
enjoy them more when it's something I'm
not deeply invested in so that's let's
say I'll never get around to watching to
my might but I'll be slow to get to it
favorite Batman villain Oh
I mean broadly speaking in terms of just
grin on my face when they show up the
ventriloquist I'm not gonna say that
they're like the best ever but like the
Joker's so overused at this point and
the Joker can still be used well despite
being overused especially because he's
so malleable he can do so many things
with him but I really do love the
ventriloquist I can't even really
justify why but I do I've been playing
Dark Souls i can now say i've been
defeated several times by a goat and
some dogs as well as cursed by
ridiculous looking lizards
three-and-a-half stars um I have the
first Dark Souls game I started playing
it
God probably over a year ago and then I
stopped not for any particular reason
but just because it's hard for me to
stick with video games for a long time
do they don't have the time from that
said I do need to get started on Paper
Mario the thousand-year door soon
because I've been commissioned for that
one
have you seen Heather's if so what is
your opinion I have not the the thing is
I most of like the iconic teen movies of
the eighties I didn't watch any time I
didn't watch when they probably would
have clicked for me I was too young in
the eighties themselves I didn't watch
them in the 90s a lot of them and the
ones that I have seen they don't work
for me most of them like I've never seen
sixteen Candles I've never seen pretty
and pink
I hate Ferris Bueller's Day Off I hate
it I cannot stand that movie I hate it
so much I hate that movie um i Breakfast
Club holds up that one's pretty good but
Heather's I never felt a desire for and
there's a whole bunch of others like
from around the same time just
as a genre this doesn't connect with me
so and I can already tell I'm falling
well behind in the chat so it's probably
gonna be one of those things where
you'll have to ask your question again
don't like spam the chat with it but
wait for me to pause and maybe try
asking again at that point I'm goo dang
it I had something I'm gonna start
watching bones because of David Boreanaz
would you recommend it have you ever
watched it I also think mine would be
season 2 finale um I've never watched
bones my mother likes bones quite a bit
so there you go wish to doctors that are
reliable you want for the next multi
doctor story I feel like I've been asked
that one almost every livestream for the
last month or so how that I'm
complaining I'm happy to answer it um I
mean I probably give a different answer
every time - uh - and 12 best angel
episode the finale the finale of angel
is one of my all-time favorite series
finales in television it's amazing and
brilliant and I love it like it's one of
the the things that it's one of those
things where if I can ever find the time
or managed to do more like deep dive
dissections of things I want to do one
on that cuz damn it you know like I did
with the lego movie - I would I would
love to do that with the would not fade
away the finality of Angel god I love
that um James Bond is the timeless child
boy have you seen any more of insight
number nine since you stopped doing
reviews of it and are you going to start
reviewing it again I have no plans start
reviewing it again I didn't move past
series 1 um and it's not that I think
it's bad it's just not quite clicking
for me that's kind of and that just
happens sometimes and also you know in
terms of actually doing reviews they
weren't particularly well viewed which
they just sound like a shell and a hack
but that is an impact on things dr. you
monster you want to return from either
class of your doctor who personally I
want the boneless to return from fly
line ok if we're talking monster as
opposed to specific character hmm that's
a good question you know um
the axons from cause of axis cuz that
was a cool idea but I don't like that at
that story your favorite Buffy episode
of according to your list was becoming
parts 1 & 2 Thank You Ben glad somebody
paid attention did you get any Easter
eggs eggs no I didn't get chocolate and
jellybeans and like gummy bunnies and
some truffles no eggs though my kid got
all the eggs hold on backing up cuz I I
keep saying I shouldn't but I do anyways
did you watch John Campea and Rob serve
Asians with Robert Myer Burnett I
literally don't know what any of those
words mean so no what's your favorite in
these favorite classic who episode do
you reviewed my favorite is city of
death least favorite um I mean probably
twin dilemma but I still stand by the
statement that it's not as bad as
everyone says it is it's not good it's
not that bad
you're wrong it's kite man or condiment
King hahahaha those are valid choices
Mae Whitman is a goddess I don't know
who that is lots of names being thrown
out that I don't know or at least don't
recognize I loved scarecrow and Killer
Croc good choices wow I'm really behind
on the chat
have you seen chilling Adventures of
Sabrina I have not liz watches that she
likes it but now I haven't seen it do
you have a favorite villain villainous
character I'm partial to the Evil Queen
from once upon a time okay if we're
saying villainous like female villains I
mean it's really hard to beat Ursula the
sea witch
oh poor unfortunate soul let's see uh
have you read fifth season slash broken
earth trilogy by n Kade
jeomsun nope I have never even heard
that
starting to read it this quarantine ah I
probably am the one who hated Breakfast
Club even at 17 I forget what age I was
when I first saw Breakfast Club I was at
a stage version of Breakfast Club when I
was in college that was a lot of fun
actually have you ever heard of the SCP
foundation I may have I I don't remember
and I don't know what means Doctor Who
locked down made a video where Arthur
Darvill as Rory made a video to Anthony
I saw that that was sweet
I like that I like that they got him to
do it having watched a legend started
watching legends of tomorrow yes a few
episodes in and snart is honestly kind
of frustrating snart was Liz's favorite
me I'm all about Mick I loved Mick but I
first season of legends of tomorrow is
the roughest it's it's uphill from there
and I still like the first season
you miss my super chat I haven't missed
it I haven't caught up to it yet cuz I'm
so freaking far behind
I started Buffy when the quarantine
started but my sister watched some and
now I can't watch any of it without her
who's your favorite character
Giles giant Oh mmm I love Giles so much
I love the depth that he gains in what
we learn about him over the course of
the show and he's got some of the most
badass moments in that show I love Giles
ah Europe Plus anthony Stewart head oh
uh what is your favorite and least
favorite classical episode yo I answered
that um I've never seen The Breakfast
Club but we aren't on DVD so I might
watch this in I think it's good British
versus American chocolate I haven't had
enough British chocolate to know like
have a taste memory on that I enjoy both
finished watching Torchwood what do you
think is the best episode from the show
best episode probably the series to
opener best villains are condiment King
caveman and Cat Man a favorite Torchwood
Chariton character oh wow favourite
Torchwood character besides Jack um I
don't really love any of them besides
Jack I guess Ianto but I'm not as in
love with Ianto as a lot of people are
what is it about Ferris Bueller
everything specifics I'm kind of poking
the bear but I like that movie it it's
Ferris himself as a character he is an
entitled spoiled prick first time I ever
watched it and I had friends who like
said it was the
movie ever first time I ever watched I
remember thinking why why am I supposed
to like him
why am I supposed to roofer why am I
supposed to be in favor of this spoiled
little dancing between the raindrops
prick who gets to weigh with everything
he's a freakin sociopath to the degree
to which he manipulates and has no
regard for the damage of anything he
does he does it because it's fun and you
need to you need to have fun while you
can or you might miss life screw you
you're 17 ah it's really up for me not
to swear talking about Ferris Bueller I
I hate him I I have a hard time thinking
of a character in more desperate need of
an ass-whooping than Ferris Bueller
favorite x-men movie x2 that uh that has
not changed and I don't think it will
did you know there's a shrine to Ianto
at Cardiff Bay I did know that I'd heard
about that sorry but Drusilla is the
best or spike both great spikes better
than drew both great but I'm sorry his
child
I enjoy being wrong what role did you
play in The Breakfast Club
I play Brian the nerd by casting says I
would it really be curious to see what
you think about the cross-dressing
sequence in the Final Fantasy 7 remake
it might surprise you well the problem
is I don't have I don't have current gen
systems I can't play it so I've been
curious as to how that would be
addressed if it would even be in there
um and I guess it is but I can't play it
I don't have the means to play the damn
game
uh how would you bring mr. Finch back
assuming you wouldn't hell yes I would
how would I bring him back he just shows
up that's it you if we don't need to
explain why the master is still alive
and we don't need to explain why Davros
is still alive we can have mr. Finch
come back this many years later and not
have to explain it have you been able to
watch any of the Doctor Who quarantine
screenings no because they pretty much
all happened during work hours and I am
still working from home how do you
rewatch Doctor Who in the u.s. well for
me I own I own these series so like I'm
I still buy physical media crazy so I go
downstairs and get the blue right off
the shelf that's how I watch it
what do you think of series 4 of
Torchwood miracle day I have not seen it
that's the one bit of torch torch what I
haven't seen would you rather ace travel
with 10 or Donna travel with 7 ooh can
we have both why must I choose oh dang
it's been the game and the way they go
about it is glorious I mean I've been
curious
I would imagine French would just walk
in with fabulous and saying hey have you
seen killing Eve I have not do you think
jack will be in revolution of the Daleks
how do you want the scene where Jack
meets 13 to go down um I don't think
he'll be in that one I expect he'll be
back in the next series proper how do I
want that meeting to go um I want him to
try and go in for a kiss and she dodges
him the doctor is uh Martin Amis
character winks at the British boomers
in the room okay I don't know what that
means
a fighting at least favorite story was
the two doctors or did you finally
repress the memory of that one oh god I
did oh you're right oh oh yeah that
one's way worse than twin dilemma God
what a what a waste that uh oh
dang it why did you remind me of that
huh fun fact Jason Momoa and Dominic
Purcell were on a terrible soap opera
Santa ye before Dominic went to prison
break hey lots of actors started in
terrible soap operas have you seen the
fifth doctor episode time flight if so
I'm sorry nope I've not gotten to that
one yet eventually I want to get around
to all of classics so someday have you
read the Marvel comic 16:07 I have I own
it
it's been a long time though my memories
of it are hazy at this point would you
rather watch hell bent or the two
doctors oh I don't know cuz what
whatever one I think I would settle for
I would be wishing that I did the other
one instead I oh that's like ask me to
pick between Chinese water torture on
the hobbling wheel if the eleventh
doctor had his own master which what
sort of actor would you choose to play
him oh goodness I have no clue that
that's one I I'm I would have to sit
down and think about how do you access
the first Doctor series I have brick box
is how I see classic ooh sorry I brought
up the memory of that Doctor Who story I
promise on that for her bring up
warriors of the deep sea worries of the
deep is so inept Lee executed it's got
an okay ish story but it's just it's
fall downs are on the production level
and so if you know how bad it's gonna be
going in and has a camp factor to
doctors is just a waste worst thing
about quarantine is trying to write
scripts for a show you're planning
having the time to do it in getting
stuck with writers I wish that I had
time to do more writing I just I don't
cuz you know I'm still doing full 40
hours a week at the job and yeah
what would you react won't be a reaction
of the azure blue off came back mild
surprise I figured the absorber off is
the kind of thing that won't be brought
back
in this run of Doctor Who if it ever
goes on hiatus again he gets revived I
could see like a showrunner in 20 years
being like who I'm gonna bring that back
but do it good
why hasn't CW released mix book it's
apparently really good and if they ever
did would you read it um I'm not sure
I'd read it just because I don't know if
I have that much time to sink into a
novelty but why are you in my live feed
I'm not supp to you hey what is what is
it with people who leave comments or
things like why am I seeing this as if
the Creator somehow controls the
algorithm and they personally put their
video or their live stream in front of
your eyes I don't know why you're seeing
me I've got something else if you want
something else
guy huh as far as why hasn't why haven't
they released some big well because
they'd have to pay someone to write it
and it probably won't make that much
back it would be it would be minor
novelty sales I bet you what they could
do though is they could release like a
like a blank notebook with covers for
that I could do that wasn't there
supposed to be a Buffy reboot there was
um there was gonna be one and there was
gonna be they were gonna have an
african-american Buffy and I was
actually game for that I thought if you
were gone reboot if that was a good way
to do it to change it up so that you're
talking to a very different high school
experience than Buffy's middle-class
white semi privileged high school
experience I thought that was a decent
idea I haven't heard anything about that
in a while though I don't know if it
ever moved forward or if it stalled or
what who knows anymore
which version of the Masters Dead or
Alive would you put in the same story
for me it's Dewan Missy and Jackie me
I can't really argue with that lineup
hahaha
although I feel like Missy and dawan are
their energy is a little too similar
they both kind of have that manic thing
going not to say that they're exactly
the same time not um but either one of
them with Jacobi would be would be very
interesting Martin Amis is a British
actor British author who wrote about
yuppies and brats okay cool
worries of the deep isn't the worst
thing in the world everyone throws it
around as the absolute bottom of the
barrel for TV let alone Doctor Who I
mean the thing was it it probably did
more damage to Doctor Who than any other
single episode in terms of its standing
in pop culture and at the BBC but you
know as an episode unto itself it's not
the worst thing ever okay would you want
the absorbable offer Clara to come back
bring back the absorb all offers I'll be
gone when you see this but I'm hoping
you have a good night Oh Thank You
Christie ah see
we need more joss whedon in my opinion
well he's working on a new show um HBO I
think um I still enjoy his work but you
know I'm a little more I'm a little
softer I'm weeding than I used to be I'm
just sad they couldn't bring back
Anthony had to play galavan's dad they
got weird out to be the official at the
wedding and Nick Frost to be the giant
yeah that was a little bit of a bummer
but I mean you know scheduling it's a
thing love the blade video every point
was fine
oh thank you I'm glad somebody actually
watched that one Jews were not great on
that video have you finished the Missy
Big Finish yes I finished series one of
that review for that will go up next
month I didn't want to
ooh too many Big Finish reviews in a row
have you seen the farewell Sarah Jane
audio short no I have I talked about it
earlier in the stream I started to but I
got distracted because I was actually
watching the video and they have the guy
performia which completely takes me out
of it I need to try again I haven't I've
been taking the time to do that yet
my least favorite Doctor Who episode is
the empty child alright let me finish
this comment before I say anything the
plot was good but I was quite young when
I saw any gave me nightmares for weeks
got to go thanks for a fun tonight
oh okay if you're mad at an episode
because it's freaked you out of child
legitimate there's a Star Trek the next
generation episode I think it's called
conspiracy that's freaked me out when I
was a kid that gave me nightmares
and I don't really like that episode as
a result even though other people say
it's good so you know what I will I will
let that pass even though that is one of
my favorite episodes of the show
favorite black mirror episode San
Junipero easy piece of cake hands down
I find that de Wong would go into a rage
Missy would be outright crazy and play
mind games Jacobi would be plenty and
scheming and stab everyone in the back
well yes that's that's what he does
is there an upcoming infinity saga
ranking over the last few movies of
phase three Oh huh you know I actually
I've been thinking about doing something
MCU related but I hadn't that it
occurred to me that I haven't rewrite
the dang things yeah yeah that's not a
bad idea
I might integrate that with something
else that I was working on I think about
that random thought after re-watching
Heaven Sent again I realize I just can't
get into any Groundhog Day type movies
with the exception of Groundhog Day
itself oh that's a shame
Oh what kind of music do you listen to I
am all over the map
I don't consistently listen to any type
specifically your cat's video made me
drink out of obligation ah what do you
think Jody Whitaker's master would be
like if she was the master in Sasha
diwan's doctor if he was the doctor
would be like I have no idea like I
don't even know how to begin to wrap my
head around that question I don't know
how they play them I don't I I don't
know how to engage with the question
like that and that's not me saying it's
a bad question
I'm just think it's a question that I I
can't do anything with yeah tangey
conspiracy is pretty gross yeah yeah it
is have you watched beast star on
Netflix no I saw a trailer for what is
that
what is that thing I remember seeing it
and going this looks like something my
kid might like him insane rated tv-ma
I'm like what what the hell is it I I
don't know I watched a trailer and I
still don't know god damn my chest is
getting huge oh okay sorry I got
distracted by my own yeah oh my god
you've worked so much British TV you're
pronouncing your H is like this are you
a small giant or a tall dwarf I'd watch
a lot of British stuff we wouldn't they
say where I pronounced an H I don't know
oh I should go check on the herb garden
[Music]
hang on odd this thing I keep trying to
I keep trying to just go down a little
bit and it jumps me to the bottom of the
chat I freaking hate this um if I wrote
for Doctor Who I would write an episode
where Clara returns and reveals the
identity of the midnight entity I would
hunt you down
have you heard Anthony Stuart heads
rendition of sweet transvestite I have
good stuff sorry about the empty child
thing I am going to try to rewatch it
after five years I have to go alright
well best of best of all I can have a
good night
I'm got to go much-loved of night John
lots of people yeah going to bed
probably partly because the stream
started later than usual sorry for
starting it up um a little on the late
side I actually took it online for less
class that a friend of mine ran cuz I am
missing that part of my life right now
quite a bit Buffy versus Black Widow who
would win well Buffy like Black Widow
would be hard to hit but Buffy only has
to land one hit she'd break Natasha in
half
have you seen the new red dwarf feet red
dwarf feature-length special I have not
yet I only just caught up I only just
finished watching series 12 of Red Dwarf
yesterday so no I haven't but it's on my
on my to-do list where would you rank
rise of Skywalker in your Star Wars
rankings Oh lower half like specifically
where I don't know I don't say it to be
insulting because I really liked him but
B stars is basically edgy Zootopia hmm
you mentioned before you don't think the
fifth doctor has a true definitive
companion is there a companion from
classic or modern who do you think would
have worked for his doctor honestly I
think Tegan or Nyssa could and should
have been his definitive companion but
they were always sharing space a with
each other and B usually with somebody
else too and I think those are about the
close as he as close as he came but
because there was there wasn't a ton of
emphasis put on those relations
chips it just didn't feel as tight as it
should have been the nightmare-inducing
baby-faced mice from cats elevate the
film from an insult the felines to an
insult to all species on earth love your
earrings thank you I noticed one of the
faces that's shown in the brain of Morey
is then on the timeless child appear
earlier in the third doctor story the
colony in space as the Time Lord judge
Oh huh I haven't I haven't seen colony
in space or brain of Morbius yet I need
to my replied to chest comment Vieira
are you telling me in livestreams in the
future we'll have to remind you thank
you that your eyes are up here
uh yeah I I am I'm not gonna lie I am
ugly myself a little bit
does your mum like Doctor Who she does
not enough to like catch up all the way
through but I know she's seen Eccleston
she's senile Tennant I think she saw
she's definitely seen most of Smith I
couldn't get her to move onto Capaldi
she she decides you would rather watch
other stuff I had to watch food fight
for a podcast never again I'm sorry that
one is filed very very sharply under
someone would have to pay me
Doctor Who idea Clara returns an episode
called Clara Oswald is day off see now
you're just baiting me did you ever come
across the Marvel crossover between
Power Man and Iron Fist naa not Doctor
Who while Marvel UK had the Who license
no less me personally no I'm familiar
with it cuz Linkara did a review of it
and I've seen his video on it
but no I have not personally read it
you're ahead of me we're just restarting
suit series 7 oh well catch on up
what did you think about episode 6 of
Westworld I liked it pretty well I'll
probably do a review when Episode seven
comes out I'll cover six and seven and
then I'll do the finale as its own thing
I liked it pretty well I like I'm
enjoying what they're doing with William
I think what they've done with Charlotte
Loras is what I've come to call her I
thought that was cool uh it was it was
better than episode 5 episode 5 felt off
to me episode 5 felt like on spectacle
in a way that didn't quite fit
let's see best to live-action Batman
actors um Michael Keaton in Adam West
I've seen the character of sir
hammerlock and Wainwright Jacobs in
borderland 3 no because again don't have
courage in gaming systems can't play it
I have Borderlands 2 I never got around
to finishing it uh what do you think of
Harry Sullivan as a character as I sorry
as a companion and knowing he was not
really supposed to be
since the doctor they chose was younger
than they wanted Harry what I don't like
about Harry is he he adopts a very
staying the ship little girl attitude
towards Sarah Jane and the more I see of
Harry and the more times I see him do
anything like that like stay behind and
be safe he pisses me off
no matter what they pay you it won't be
enough that's probably true but you know
I am for sale that's the simple fact
question is do you think I'm worth the
price Oh what was that what are we doing
uh what show or film saga would you have
Doctor Who crossover with none of them I
don't really like crossovers franchise
crossovers as a rule like I don't
consider any of the MCU stuff to be
crossover cuz they're all already
supposed they're built to actually be in
the same universe that's different
actual franchise crossovers for things
never meant to connect I don't
something always is off and I basically
only ever enjoy those things when
they're silly like the Batman scooby-doo
thing I enjoyed cuz it was silly because
the the whole premise is inherently
silly
but as a general rule I'm not I'm not
big fan of those things favorite non
sympathetic villains oh um huh I'd have
to stop and think about that excuse me
100% agree with the Batman actors thank
you
what would your ideal what would what
would be your ideal Doctor Who villain
ah I don't have an ideal one it's a bit
like I don't have an ideal doctor whose
story I don't even have an ideal doctor
whose series because one of my favorite
things about the show is its
malleability in that it doesn't have to
do the same thing over and over and over
again so I don't have a definitive
favorite I got a check the discord thank
you for the reminder Karen I don't know
if there's gonna be much in there since
there this was a topic lists live stream
I love it when a lack of a plan comes
together
that's that's the story of my life no
plan but somehow I pull it together
looks like it is women on the verge of a
nervous breakdown
ooh boy aah what's everyone done
different these days I'm still working
as an earth nurse with developmentally
disabled but when I get out I've been
working on reading more oh well that's
good I have a book club now with my
church so I've been focused on the book
called midnight riot don't know that one
no I'm glad you do reading more I wish I
could started reading World War Z and
then started and have been reading
midnight riot I'm actually wanting to
start Thunderhead but I don't want to
since I already have to I'm reading
simultaneously I don't props you for
being able to do that I can't read more
than one book at a time
um Shh question about the time that it
was on how much would it cost for me to
get you to review all the fire escape
and the Peacekeeper Wars um Wow
um a lot uh I think it would depend on
whether you were looking for episode by
episode reviews or whether you were
willing to take season reviews um if you
wanted episode by episode that's gonna
run yo Walt um I don't know off the top
my head what's your opinion on Joss
Whedon's writing directing over the
years um asked before he came up with a
live screen hey girl when it seems
redundant um I mean like I think I think
he's a clever writer I don't think he's
done much to evolve in the last decade
maybe even 20 years he's good at what he
does but I don't feel like I feel like
he's found his groove and he's happy to
stay in it which is fine but he had
struck me as the kind of creator who was
gonna keep evolving and he hasn't and
that's how soured me on him but you know
uh and somebody put never gonna give you
up as a gift in there funny thing um the
the burlesque class that I hated the
song we were dancing we were learning
the choreography too was this slow jazz
version of never gonna give you up I
found that amusing on reflection I think
series 11 has two of the best of the
Honu who era demons are the Punjab and
it takes you away would you agree that
these are hired better than the best of
12 I don't know about that cuz as much
as I like it takes you away and I like
it takes you away a lot and I like teams
of the Punjab
I was really bowled over by can you hear
me like that
that one really knocked me on my ass but
those are those are the two best
episodes of series 11 so if you're gonna
make an argument for the best of that
series that those are the ones to go
with okay coming on back to the chat uh
see I'm so far behind now um véra name
your price Chiqui uh what's your
thoughts on Tegan and Nyssa being
confirmed as a couple in the farewell I
haven't finished it yet and I hadn't
heard that so you're either trolling me
or you just spoil something for me so
how do you rate Buffy the musical dunno
I haven't seen it
well done Harry you're getting to use
your head of course you mustn't
congratulate because I've rubbed off on
you first Marvel comic you've never read
Morbius issue or I think which companion
would you bring back besides Donna knew
who only bill have you ever seen
primeval and fine evil he primeval no I
am NOT I love that you're not a Doctor
Who fan or a hater to many of those on
YouTube I do consider myself to be a
Doctor Who fan I'm not a I am NOT a a
100 percent everything's amazing kind of
person I'm not a cheerleader I'm not a
I'm not I'm not someone who makes
excuses for the show but I do consider
myself a fan I love Doctor Who most of
the time no playing and coming together
sounds like a very doctoral way of doing
things oh I will take that as a
compliment I still don't get black
panther it's been bugging me for the
past month I also don't get watermelon
the middle and JK rowling because George
Lucas making this being George Lucas
making the special editions I feel like
I'm coming in on something that idea I
feel like this context I don't
understand for that comment
would you want nardole to come back as
he technically didn't die um no I think
uh I did enjoy nardole but a big part of
what I liked about him was his dynamic
very specifically with Capaldi and I
think um I think his dynamic would not
click as well without think I mean
here's here's a honest honest answer
here most companions most good
companions are properly tailored to the
doctor they're with and that's not to
say they couldn't work at all with
another doctor but they're not gonna
work as well if they've been developed
properly so I could Commission you to
watch my series in theory yes you could
how much do you think it would cost to
review a written Doctore or a couple of
them one is written by Gaiman depends on
the length like full-length novels which
I do take reviews for and I have done
those cost more than the standard review
for like a movie or two episodes of a
hour-long TV show or four episodes of a
half hour long TV show because books
take a lot longer so if they're short
stories it would probably fit within the
standard commission rate depending on
how short you might even get a couple of
them but if it's an if we're talking
novel know that that and that will cost
you more than the standard I did there
they're all teared out on the on the
patreon
Buffy The Musical must be once more with
feeling oh okay the musical episode they
meant oh I love once more with feeling
that's and that's that's a good that's a
good thing for sing-alongs then they
rest in peace
would you want to see a classic campaign
come back like they did with Sarah Jane
ace
bring back ace there is no reason to not
ah what do you think Bill's reaction
meeting thirteen with me would you like
I think she'd be slightly weirded out
because she'd suddenly be attracted to
the doctor
I didn't you just get this look on her
face like oh this is weird do you think
it would be cool with missing meth the
thirteenth doctor I think it would be
cool if Missy met like everyone every
doctor ever
have you seen warehouse 13 I have not
favorite sitcom ooh that I do I don't
know I can give you a handful of
possible ones maybe Brooklyn nine-nine
if I suppose if you consider the good
place to sitcom maybe that one maybe Red
Dwarf
it's tough snog marry kill Buffy Giles
Drusilla ah snog Buffy marry Giles
killed you're Silla I'm sorry I can't
deal with that much crazy the good chime
travel to any point in space-time where
would you go I don't know I think I just
hit the randomizer best finales to show
other than angel
cheers Cheers has a brilliant series
finale that I think is underappreciated
because it's it's a silly little sitcom
whatever was it funny then I guess it's
good no cheers finales amazing it's
really good
a spinoff on Gallifrey
I know there is there is the book that
Sophie already wrote that I want to read
do you see yourself as more of a doctor
or companion
probably a campaign just because I would
like more of these experiences to be
completely new I think too much of its
familiar to the doctor that's that if I
was going to actually portray a role and
be an actor
give me the doctor mm-hmm fun fact as a
gift for being in the Spongebob movie
David Hasselhoff got 12 foot long rubber
dummy of himself
they made the fight scene oz back yes I
did know that and that's so weird
best kisser on Downton Abbey I don't
know I've never seen it ah
Missy versus the Seventh Doctor too
small Scottish people hitting each other
with their umbrellas Oh that'd be
brilliant
I'd be amazing uh would you ever do a
review of adult life skills it comes to
Netflix May first I've never even heard
of it so I don't know let's see I
commend you to be tormented by watching
the Seinfeld finale forever
Seinfeld finales not as bad as everyone
seems to think it is it's not great it's
a letdown but it's not powerful
Dexter series finale is awful Buffy
finale was out hang on lost it I got a
backup
Buffy finale was pretty good but they
should have killed Andrew not Anya the
final episode is good I don't like most
of that season though Brooklyn nine-nine
Season 7 comes out on Netflix Friday
nice would you save rose or coal from
the war master probably coal I really
wanted companion to be revealed to be a
villain but not to turn out to be an
alien or monster that we've seen before
basically to be the grant Ward of Doctor
I I think the only way to pull that off
if they're not gonna be an alien if they
are just gonna be within the standard
pool of what companions tend to be you'd
have to timey-wimey it you have to have
it be where whatever reason the
companion has for wanting to harm the
doctor be something that happened in
their past but the doctors future so
that when they start traveling with the
doctor they already have formed in their
head this opinion of how horribly is and
what they want to do to mess with him
but the doctor has no idea because he
hasn't done whatever pissed them off yet
I think that would be what you'd have to
do to have that work have you ever seen
an amnesia plotline you like did whoever
attempt one um who did briefly at the
start of the eighth doctor's TV movie he
has amnesia for a hot minute um is there
an amnesia story that I like well you
could argue that memento is an amnesia
story of a type
it's an unusual one but it effectively
is there's some others I almost love
dark City it's like that close it falls
apart real hard at the end though bear
are you watching Deb's no I don't know
what that is
Turlough got redeemed though yeah he did
let's see quantum leap finale was bleak
yeah
and a text crawl of all things that was
weird
like I never watched quantum leap but I
know about that
do you watch Tarantino films I have not
seen the latest one I have not seen Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood yet I have seen
all of his others um he's a filmmaker
who enjoys movies but I only ever
watched them once I think Jobs was
supposed to get his own spin-off there
was talk about it for a while it's gonna
be called Ripper and there was actually
Whedon was in negotiations with the BBC
to have them co-financed it and produced
it there so that anthony Stewart head
could stay in England because he didn't
want to come back to the u.s. to do it
um it had never pulled together I know
that was talked about it though there
was also talk about made-for-tv movies
starring spike I didn't pull together
either the companion could be an alien
or someone from a different time period
as long as that's what they were
introduced as when they were a companion
although like the time you wind the idea
yeah like on I like an alien companion
but I don't want it to be like surprise
alien to me like just having companion
or somebody from the past like seriously
why not it is it any more unbelievable
that somebody from 500 years ago can
accept what the doctor is then we can I
mean he's so far advanced of
us that it might as well we might as
well be from 500 years from where we are
now it's uh just I'm sick of modern
error companions modern day
let's see
it was gonna be like Hellblazer yeah
that was what I heard the Giles show
films and often don't film synopsis of
adult life skills Anna played by Jodie
Whittaker finds herself living in her
mother's shed and recording videos her
friendship with two people inspires her
to finally grow up does not sound like
my kind of show I mean it's a perfectly
legitimate premise um but you know does
doesn't doesn't sound like me do you
think Captain Jack remember song would
ever get together I think if they did
the universe might explode by sheer
force of innuendo what do you think
about a Bruce Campbell appearing on
Doctor Strange new movie does that
confirmed I hadn't heard that I'm fading
so we'll jump the ship neither is
everyone all right pirates I'm gonna be
wrapping it up soon and myself I've
actually gone a little long versus how
long these normally go so hang on but an
alien would stand out in Earth's history
episodes so so what people act like you
can't write around that like but you can
like so what I'm not and I'm not mad at
you for pointing that out
I've just I hear that as an argument for
why we must always have a modern day and
human companion no we don't write
creatively work around it take the
opportunities that it gives you ah I'm
uppity tonight apologies for that unless
you find that entertaining in which case
consider supporting my patreon if doctor
who had to do a crossover voice TV or
film okay if you got on
if you're gonna back me against a wall
for it let's somebody brought it up
earlier so let's go Farscape that works
I've discovered my vocal range is like
the gestures and the opening song voices
most of gesture is in my range so like I
can do the main Gallivan song just fine
actually what I'm when I'm feeling
ambitious I will try to sing the jesters
recap song from like the tail end of the
second season the one that's the sped up
version of him recounting like
everything that's gone on that season if
if I if I was sure that I wouldn't that
the live stream wouldn't get shut down
because I'm singing copyrighted material
I'd give it a go
cuz I'm had a drink so I'm braver now
but I'm not gonna because I'm pretty
sure the boss would catch me Jamie
McCrimmon was a second doctor campaign
from the past and he kept up with the
doctor and he was also one of the best
companions ever Jamie's great if you
don't think so you are not invited to my
birthday party yeah all they did for mr.
Spock was give him a hat huh but counsel
we can't have a name you an alien
Communion because because marketing yeah
Buffy meets Torchwood that would be a
crossover Oh that'd be something doctor
Doctor Who and Muppets haha
do you think it could ever work out if a
real-life historical figure became an
official series long companion for the
doctor I'd really rather they didn't
like could it work
maybe I don't I wouldn't recommend that
any news on your Doctor Who hitchhiker
analysis
tune in on towel day Oh Carolyn don't
sulk look if I held the copyrights of
these songs I would happily sing them
but I don't favor monitor banging Donna
can we agree the best episode of
galavan's is the second season opener we
have the new season in the enchanted
forest
um I don't know if I can't agree with
that doctor who would them up it's
already happened no that's true I saw
that um like I would have a hard time
nailing down a single specific favorite
episode of galavant season two is better
and I do like season 1 but Mary Shelley
was a companion I should didn't like her
sorry silver torch fans uh-huh an
episode of Doctor Who were Cheech and
Chong hot barks the TARDIS maybe it's
cuz I'm too old I don't find teaching
Chung funny maybe because I'm not a
STONER Doctor Who or galavant well it
would be Doctor Who just for the breadth
and amount of stuff you get for that
galavant is two seasons two great
seasons that I love but you know just by
volume of what you get it's not a good
that's not a good deal I want a sci-fi
dystopian story where everything we do
is monitored by copyright BOTS I have um
not a STONER by the way happy belated
4/20 ha ha ha ha I have a concept in my
head for what would be under most
circumstances a dystopia story but my
ideas that it is that I was gonna say is
that it works that might be an
overstatement but like I want to set
something in
most people would consider a dystopian
setting and not have a story be about
taking down that system just have it
happen there and for the most part the
system does appear to actually work have
you thought about those unsympathetic
villains well no because they've been
rambling off on other questions
um I've got Ursula in my head again oh
man I don't know I did that there's
others I'm just I'm drawing a blank I'm
getting tired of how to drink
I should be wrapping up so not sure if
anyone care what my birthday is in four
days
happy birthday crystal
isn't this hope in future that doesn't
get changed idea basically KaBlam kind
of all you know just hope in outer space
even yeah kind of
for me I'll say killgrave real-world
evil ooh that's yeah good pick good pick
that sounds like a really great idea for
a novel would totally read that well see
the thing is as well that's one of those
things there's a number of things where
I have really good settings and concepts
but I don't have I don't have a
narrative on full lockdown and that's
one of those I've got another one where
like I wrote it as a short story and
like I like it as a short story but I'm
like I could if I could figure out an
actual narrative to build around this
concept I could totally give a
full-length novel it's it's a core
concept that totally could be stretched
out but I just can't figure out a story
to do it which is frustrating
I've also got a fantasy setting that
where like I came up with an entire
world and magic system that I really
like but I could never figure out a
story to put there yeah I I had another
thing that was I came up with an arc for
one character but I wanted it to be
ensemble show and I couldn't figure out
what to do with anybody else I couldn't
even come up with a full cast for the
rest of it it's like when you can when
all the pieces come together it's magic
so often it's like I've got like three
out of five pieces but this doesn't hold
together without the missing bits and I
can create a process it's a [ __ ] I said
that word really loud is any of your
writing available online at present no I
mean my my book that I wrote about my
life experience as a gender-fluid person
that is for sale on Amazon and I sort of
play that's available on Amazon but and
the play adult audience for the play if
you're someone who actually is going to
read a play in the first place but like
those are available but the sorts of
things I'm talking about like the short
stories and the novel like I I'm working
on getting the novel published I'm gonna
I'm hopefully gonna be pulling together
a Kickstarter to to get that
self-published later this year that's
the goal for that I just saw your second
review of Rosa and I don't know whether
or not you were talking about has
happened in any way but we will stand
and fight well it yeah it did happen and
I'm not gonna rehash all this but it ya
know it just did there's nothing to
fight because this is look I try not to
talk overtly about politics I'll talk
about political themes and issues in
shows and movies and whatever but um I
don't talk straight-up politics a ton
and I try not to cuz I figure my
politics aren't too much about the
people's business most people probably
don't want to hear them and you know I
don't I'm not looking to alienate
anybody and I'd like to think that my
politics shouldn't matter but it
shouldn't be a shock to know where I
stand on a lot of issues especially
anything related to lgbtq+ and what is
been the single most infuriating thing
about this administration is everything
that they could do without needing
oversight everything that fell
completely within the purview of the
presidency they have just done and
regardless of outcry regardless of
injury regardless of damage so that
thing that I talked about in that second
review of
where the Trump administration made it
the official stance of the federal
government that there are only two
genders and they are immutable and they
do not change from what you were
assigned at Birth there's nothing to
fight he decides he's gonna do that he
can just do that he did because it's
the presidency is a weird thing the
president is not an elected King the
president is not despite what mr. Trump
but have us believe he does not have he
is not all-powerful he cannot do just
whatever he wants but the President does
have a lot of powers a lot of unchecked
powers and they're not necessarily at
high level he can't make new laws he
can't you know appropriate funding all
of that still falls within the purview
of the legislature but what he can do
and what he has done is got agencies he
doesn't like got their funding put
people in charge of it who don't like
those agencies they never has to just
handle them from the outside to change
guidelines not laws strictly speaking
but the official position of the United
States government to change that on a
whim can he has and will continue to for
as long as he's in office so
it's a frustrating time because and this
is what happens when someone who truly
doesn't care about what people think and
it's why it's a bad idea to have someone
who truly doesn't care what people think
in charge because they by definition
they will not do what is desired or in
the interest of the majority of the
populace over which they are intended to
govern they're gonna do whatever they
want and no matter what side of the
political aisle you stand on no matter
where you are on issues the leader
should care what the people they lead
want how they feel about what they're
doing they they should care it shouldn't
dictate absolutely everything they were
do but they should give a damn and even
if you like Trump you have to admit the
man doesn't give a damn what anyone
thinks so he doesn't care who he hurts
he doesn't really care who he helps
either he's gonna do what he wants to do
I'm sorry for bringing this up ah it's
alright I'm sorry for bringing everybody
down by latching onto it I could have
let it go and then the the frustrating
thing is you were giving me a vote of
support so I'm sorry for bringing
everybody down you might want to look at
unbound crowdfunding website for books I
don't know much about it but I've seen a
number of book campaigns run through
there recently I'm familiar with it I
know Laura Dale
did a book through that I'm I might look
into it I'm hesitant just because the
way that it works seems very strange to
me and it also seems to take for ever
like I remember like the branded hers is
the only one I know but I remember her
unbound campaign it was like six months
ago it ended and the books still not out
which is strange to me I should look
into it I'm I'm 10 I'm favoring
Kickstarter because I've run a
Kickstarter before so I know Kickstarter
I know it is a platform I know how it
works I know how to run it I might look
into unbound will see I gotta figure out
the pluses and minuses on it would you
be interested in watching knots and
crosses miniseries no I don't know
anything about it scribbles I am the
authority on the wall and crayon oh
thank goodness
can't pretend to know what that feels
like
my only saying sorry it doesn't do much
by truly am sorry you know what it it
helps like when the person in charge
doesn't care knowing that there are
other people who do it does help because
it's it's tempting in your dark moments
you think well if the person at the top
doesn't care and he was voted in then I
guess nobody cares
so getting reassurance that that isn't
the case honestly it does help so thank
you alright
ah I prefer Harold Saxon divorce Johnson
here in Britain if you were the doctor
what would you want to see behind the
diamond wall from
heaven-sent oh I don't know just warm
Sun in a gentle rain
all right so I am gonna wrap it up I I
hope people didn't get too bummed out by
my little um Chilean Nathan beer man oh
thanks for tonight um I I hope it's like
a better story behind Simon wall uh so I
hope everyone does okay I hope you stay
safe stay home bye
it sucks I know it sucks I'm doing it I
know it starts but stay home stay safe
be well and thanks for coming by so just
remember that you're beautiful you are
valid you are loved
you're the council and I'm just running
meetings
take care